tonight there's one more job I've got to
do to complete our mission I need to
attach a transmitter to a large female
to see if her nesting habits change as
the dam floods her home
I'm looking for about a nine to eleven
foot crowd but then I'll definitely have
to check it sex
it's not big
may it may be a female it's perfect size
for a female this may be a good
candidate for the transom there we got
to get another rope maybe under the rope
and she needs some help
she's got a stone lodged in her mouth a
huge rock is wedged under her top job
he's got a stone stuck in her mouth and
there's no telling how long it's been
there
that stone still in there first I got to
get a rope on those jobs hold on like
that okay
honest restrains the croc and I do a
little dentistry
I knock it out I like the way she's up
on all fours
if this is a female she can give us a
lot of data such as where the nesting
habitat is going to be once this Canyon
change to a more placid lake environment
one two three huh that was nice and easy
I'll have to turn her over to check her
gender Crocs over 12 feet are almost
always males but this one could be
either sex you can't tell just by
looking at this animal what sex it is
the only way to sex a crocodile is to
check the cloaca you got to stick your
fingers inside if you feel a male organ
it's obviously a male and if you don't
feel anything it's a female are you
ready I'll just roll over this way
this is the cloaca essentially one
opening for everything i get the honors
yeah that's a female this is great I
think this is a perfect individual to
put a transmitter on and she looks to be
imperfect though she's a beautiful
specimen I mean there's not a scar on
her see she's got a full tail that's
pretty rare in adult crocodiles
nine and a half feet this there's an
adult female
now she's a breeding size this is the
first time a satellite transmitter will
have ever been placed on a female Nile
crocodile so then she's sitting history
tonight gonna we're gonna the
transmitter will tell us if she returns
to her nesting site once the season
begins in October if she keeps it
emitting a signal at the same spot
constant the thing that should be a nest
but if she keeps traveling she's
probably looking for a new site perhaps
due to flood waters in the gorge
even if she finds one in time she'll
face heated competition for others
equally desperate to lay their eggs with
so few nesting sites available I mean
from what I saw there were just a few
sandy beaches if those are lost these
females are going to be lost literally
they're gonna have to find new nesting
areas yeah apart we got the transmitter
on the animal it's a beautiful placement
she's unharmed she's just really tired
or so I think still we have to release
her with extreme care
party you guys ready yep at the last
minute my cameraman Simon hops to switch
positions
it's nearly a fateful decision on the
count of three one two three the croc
head straight for Simon
he backs off just in time I'm gonna take
our camera ran out sorry here we go yeah
yeah he's finding his way to the water